in the late 1950s people began to
experiment with the idea of computer to
computer communication and all
information no matter the form is stored
in the computer's memory as a sequence
of bits to send these bits they created
hardware which could transmit a clock to
sequence of electrical pulses along the
wire on the receiving end the computer
would capture store and convert the bits
into the information they represent
doing this with two computers along a
single line is quite simple but of
course other people wanted to connect
their computers together too
leading to a computer network one simple
solution to make this network would be
to connect all machines to all other
machines but as you add more and more
computers this requires an impractical
amount of line telephone networks at the
time took a more practical approach
individuals were connected to a hub such
as a city switchboard which was a point
through which many people could connect
at this hub an operator with a
switchboard would manually patch people
together by closing a circuit between
them known as a circuit switched Network
so if person a wants to connect to
person B they both get patched onto the
long-distance line through the hub but
drawback of this method is nobody else
in the network can use that line until a
and B finish their conversation we call
this line the bottleneck of the network
by 1972 the designers of what we now
call the Internet we're building ARPANET
it began as a small network of computers
at universities on both sides of the
country connected together so they came
up with a clever way of weaving computer
conversations together by breaking up
all digital messages into chunks known
as packets
and the job of the hub is simple send
packets as they arrive in a first-come
first-serve basis each packet labeled by
its source and destination on the
receiving end this weaving is undone and
the packets are put back in their
original sequence effectively squeezing
multiple conversations along the line at
the same time new cities were connected
to hubs and those hubs were all
connected to each other so more and more
digital data needed to get squeezed down
these long distance lines but there is a
fundamental limit to how many bits you
can squeeze down any line per second
this limit is known as the line capacity
or bandwidth and as you add more and
more and more households to the network
you'll run into a problem we've all
experienced in traffic a waiting line
develops if you are watching a streaming
video you will notice these missing
packets as unwanted pauses in your
stream to see exactly how this happens
let's do a simple example and ignore all
the people on the Internet except one
household imagine this household is
watching a video stream from Washington
upstairs and downstairs someone is
listening to an audio stream from
California the video packet could take
this pathway and at the exact same time
the audio packet could take this pathway
no problem
but now let's add another household to
the network in a separate city and
assume they also want the identical
audio and video streams perhaps they're
popular shows they have a direct pathway
to the music source but they need the
middle path to get their video source
this causes a waiting line or queue to
develop so the hub will transmit two
packets down the line one after the
other this is what we mean when we say
the network is slowing down people begin
to wait for their packets due to queues
which develop at the hub so the big
engineering problem we face today is how
can we make these queues at our
bottlenecks smaller in the year 2000 a
seminal paper was published to address
this problem and it's based on a very
clever strategy for what happens at the
nodes in a network instead of treating
the packets like cars and sending them
one at a time
the idea was to instead treat packets as
numbers and blend them together using
mathematical operations such as addition
resulting in a new packet which contains
a mixture of information from more than
one packet think of these mixed packets
as providing clues as to what packets
are within them this is a very novel
idea so let's return to our example to
see exactly how it works let's say the
video packet being sent can be
represented by the number one and the
audio packet can be represented by the
number four when the video packet hits
its first hub it's the only one to
arrive so it's sent unchanged along all
output lines the same thing happens when
the music packet hits its first hub but
now look at the middle hub it receives
two packets so to avoid forming a line
it adds them together and sends the
result as a single packet
notice now that both households receive
their packets just as fast as if they
were alone on the network finally the
key step is to look at how we can unmix
these mixtures on the receiving end
let's look at household one it received
the video packet directly to extract the
music packet out of the mixture it needs
to solve for the missing value by doing
simple math we all learn in school we
know the video packet equals 1 and the
video plus the music packet equals 5
therefore the music packet equals 4 and
that's the great insight of this paper
we treat each mixture as an equation the
receiving computer solves for the
variables or packets it needs this is in
sharp contrast to how the internet was
originally designed because it allows
multiple packets to travel the same line
at the same time instead of having to
get each packet in line and wait its
turn and the system practically works
because computers can now do the basic
math to solve these linear equations
incredibly fast millions of times per
second by 2020 it is expected that 75%
of network traffic will be video streams
and the traffic from mobile phones alone
will be 30 quintillion bytes per day and
we increasingly rely on these
communication networks for services that
are considered fundamental such as
health finance education therefore
solving problems related to network
congestion is critical and network
coding is a great approach because it
allows us to mix information packets
instead of having to get each packet in
line and wait it's turn this video
presented the basic principle of network
coding in a simplified manner but there
still exists many open questions as well
as new applications to explore such as
wireless networks security distributed
computing and storage an active research
area and information theory today is how
to best leverage this paradigm
to network coding as we build our
digital future
you